this is my terrible attempt to ask about
the next doctor strange movie did you
get
did you get what you what you needed for
that film
or was it a situation where you got the
full script
um we i think we have a we have we
always are changing right because we're
always giving notes and they
are very kind to welcome opinions and
thoughts and so
it's always an evolution even while
you're filming
but we have we definitely have a script
but when i was told i would be in it
there
i had no idea what it was gonna be i
just know i was gonna be a doctor
strange too
and it wasn't only until um before we
even went back to do re
to finish one division during the
pandemic that i i found out
um what i am doing and dr
strange too but it's kind of nice to not
know you just you just kind of trust the
trust everyone and then you
bring your experience of the character
to it and
and people welcome changes once you
become more involved
i i like hearing that i think that's
part of the reason why the
characters keep growing in an
interesting way one more doctor strange
question for you just because i'm a huge
fan of sam raimi but in particular like
i'm a die-hard evil dead fan and i kind
of want to see him bring that
irreverence to the mcu so
is there anything he's done for you as a
leader on that set that
i don't know maybe could have that evil
dead touch to it that i want so badly
he's an incredible person to work with
he's just such a unique human
and i just think it's fun getting to
work with someone with such
um specific um goals
and i love his use of camera and it's
definitely like
a use of camera that i'm not used to at
all
so i guess that might answer your
question i i'm picturing certain things
right now and i think i like what i'm
picturing
[Music]